What's up everyone?
Jared here,
a few months ago,
we got an email from a fan named red
requesting a video comparing the
portrayal of nihilism in rick and morty
and bojack horseman,
so we hit up our resident nihilism
expert and sweatiest writer,
a wise crack Michael Burns to take a
stab at it,
and if you guys have requests to be sure
to subscribe and hit us up with some
ideas.
So thanks to read,
we're going to give you guys a crash
course into contemporary nihilism with
legendary lotharios rick Sanchez and
bojack horseman.
Save it for Youtube.
So welcome to this wisecrack addition on
nihilism with bojack and rick.
And as always,
spoilers ahead.
Many assume that nihilism simply means
believing in nothing.
Nothing Lebowski Nacin,
but it actually refers to a number of
philosophical,
psychological and ethical positions.
And while they all differ,
these different flavors of nihilism all
begin from the shared premise that there
is no inherent meaning value or order in
life.
Gentlemen,
here's a solution here.
You're not seeing,
although many in the edge,
Lord might get a kick out of using
nihilists catchphrases to show the world
their heart of darkness.
You don't speak because of Friedrich
Nietzsche.
In reality,
most of these folks miss out on the
complexity of nihilism rather than a
philosophy best embodied by tyler
durden.
Nihilism can be the basis for meaningful
worldviews.
Today we're going to narrow our focus
down to two different branches of
nihilism,
existential nihilism and cosmic
also known as cosmic pessimism to help
us navigate the wonderful world of
existential nihilism.
We'll be talking about everyone's
favorite functionally alcoholic horse
bojack horseman,
and to provide insight into the cold
rationality of cosmic nihilism.
We're turning to another functional
alcoholic,
Rick Sanchez,
but don't worry even if you have a
healthy relationship with alcohol,
you'll still be able to figure out which
nihilism is right for you.
Part one,
existential nihilism.
Existential nihilism is nihilism
experience.
When we realized that there is no
inherent meaning to our lives and at its
core,
human existence is just a precarious
dance upon the grave.
It's up to us to create meaning in our
lives through our own freedom and
decisions.
We can have values,
but we must create and sustain them,
and it's this worldview which fuels
bojack horseman.
I'm responsible for my own happiness.
I can't even be responsible for my own
breakfast,
but before we get into the nihilists
undercurrents of bojack horseman,
let's take a look back at the history of
nihilism.
The term nihilism,
which first coined at the end of the
18th century by German philosopher
Friedrich Jacoby and Response to
enlightenment reason which you worried
would explain away the conditions for
religion.
This rationalist med that explained way,
any spaces of uncertainty or mystery
rendering,
everything there was knowable,
sound,
familiar,
well scientifically traditions or an
idiot thing.
One of the first philosophers to think
through the implications of nihilism was
Soren Kierkegaard,
who the New York Times has referred to
as the Danish doctor of dread.
Although kingergarten ever used the
word,
existentialism is regarded as one of the
fathers of modern existentialism and
walk.
He wasn't known for the substance abuse
typical for many nihilist.
He did pour so much sugar into his
coffee that it piled up above the
liquid,
like an iceberg warning of adult onset
diabetes,
true story,
which is insane and probably more
dangerous than sipping scotch before you
get out of bed.
Trigger Guard thought that despair was
an essential part of the human
experience,
which he referred to as the sickness
unto death.
This human despair is dialectical,
which basically means you're always at
odds with yourself or to put
differently.
I don't know how to be.
Diane doesn't get better and it doesn't
get easier.
I can't keep lying to myself saying I'm
gonna Change.
I'm poisoning.
For example,
were either in despair because we think
nothing is possible.
It happened again.
Why do I keep thinking?
Things will make me happy.
What is wrong with me or we despair
because we think everything is possible
and can't make a decision.
What should I do?
Make a break for it.
Drive to Mexico,
start a new life there.
Made a local girl fall in love,
talked my way into a line job at a
textile plant.
Gradually worked my way up until I owned
the place.
Now,
what am I talking about?
I can't run a textile plant.
That's way too much responsibility.
Oh,
what am I going to do it?
The walls are closing in.
We're in in despair
about being who we are.
Am I just do them to be the person that
I am the person in that book or in
despair because we can't be who we think
we are all this time I assumed there was
more to me than everyone thought,
but maybe there isn't this despair is
the root of the melancholy that plagues
much of the human experience.
The same melancholy we see in almost all
of the characters of bojack horseman
from Todd's worries about his sexuality.
I think I'm a sexual to princess.
Carolyn's anxieties about motherhood.
Your pregnancy is no longer viable.
Well,
how do we make it viable again,
except Mr.
peanut butter,
he seems fine and of course bojack is a
character that seems to have it all
successful acting career,
beautiful home money and women.
Yet he can't seem to enjoy any of it and
even when seemingly good things happen
to him,
he manages to either feel disappointed.
You're an Oscar nominee.
How do you feel?
I feel I feel I feel the same or
sabotaged his own happiness.
Just to be clear,
since this morning,
you ate all the muffins.
Yeah.
I eat them all in one sitting because I
have no self control and I hate myself.
No matter what decision he makes,
he's marked by regret and no matter how
well things work out,
bojack is haunted by an unshakeable
despair.
Here regard describes this experience in
his book,
either or if you marry,
you will regret it.
If you do not marry,
you will also regretted rather you marry
or you do not marry,
you will regret both.
No matter what bojack does,
whether it's virtuous or selfish,
the stench of regret follows.
Look what I did to the people I'm
supposed to care about.
I had sex with the one person I've ever
seen you be in love with and for
Kierkegaard.
This isn't an exception to the human
condition.
It's the very nature of the human
We see bojack experiencing this type of
self doubt during an anxiety attack,
hasn't seasoned for idiot.
What'd you do all day pieces or
Kierkegaard?
Anxiety is caused by the uncertainty
that lies beneath every decision and he
considers anxiety.
One of the ways that we experience
freedom because we're free,
we're responsible for our own decisions
and the way that these decisions leads
to anxiety.
Paragraph describes this anxiety as
standing at the edge of an abyss.
Anxiety may be compared with dizziness.
He who's I happened to look down into
the yawning abyss,
becomes dizzy.
Hence,
anxiety is the dizziness of freedom and
this terrifying freedom means we can
literally do anything including botched
suicide attempts via yellow convertible
for character yard.
The only way to work through this
anxiety and despair is the acceptance of
the cosmic absurdity of reality and
living one's life by faith.
But if you're not keen on using religion
to combat meaninglessness,
don't worry.
Character Carton thinks that faith is
simply the courage to attempt a
meaningful existence in the face of a
meaningless world.
Sometimes you need to take
responsibility for your own happiness.
We see this at the conclusion of season
four.
While nothing drastic has changed,
bojack has accepted the complexity of
his relationship with his mother,
uh,
Jack Ma,
but budget is that you?
Yeah,
it's me and it's decided to find meaning
in his new little sister hollyhock.
Almost a hundred years after character
guard collapsed in the street and died,
a French philosopher named John Paul
Sartre picked up the mantle and develop
the first explicitly existentialist
philosophy and in a move that both rick
and bojack would love.
Sartre had many of his philosophical
insights while drinking at bars in
Paris.
While bojack himself isn't a fan,
I stand by my critique of South Sartre,
argued that existentialism is a way to
respond to the meaninglessness of the
universe by creating meaning ourselves.
So while there is no ethical value to be
found in the world,
nor a god to take comfort in humans can
create meaning through our own lives.
There may be no cure to disparity
anxiety,
but at least we can try to make our
lives meaningful.
However,
it's important to remember that while
existential nihilism offers the
possibility of a meaningful life,
eight guarantees us nothing,
and it's our responsibility to
constantly create meanings.
As kierkegaard said,
we must live forward and understand
backwards.
Closure is a made up thing by Steven
Spielberg to sell movie tickets.
It's like true love and the Munich
Olympics doesn't exist in the real
world.
The only thing to do now is just to keep
living forward part to cosmic nihilism
or pessimism.
Now that we've seen the ways in which
existential nihilism manages to offer
some meaning and hope.
Let's look at the less optimistic branch
of nihilism.
Cosmic nihilism.
Cosmic nihilism is a colder,
hyper,
rational branch of thought which argues
that there is no truth or meaning to be
found in the universe and even
constructed human meanings like freedom,
love,
hope,
and joy are just myths.
We believe in order to cope with the
empty void at the center of our reality,
even the we create our at best fables
that act as coping mechanisms.
Q,
morty.
Nobody exists on purpose.
Nobody belongs anywhere.
Everybody's going to die.
Come Watch TV
for the cosmic dial list.
It's okay to keep busy while we wait for
the coming heat death of the university,
but we're kidding ourselves if we think
we're capable of creating genuine
meaning.
For the most part,
this seems to fit the philosophy of Rick
Sanchez,
who,
while admitting nothing matters,
still waxes poetic about taking the
universe for a ride.
When you know nothing matters,
the universe is yours and I've never met
a universe that was into it.
The Universe is basically an animal at
grazes on the ordinary creates infinite
idiots just to eat them,
not unlike your friend Timmy,
Tommy.
Yeah,
hardly matters.
Now,
sweetie,
you know smart people get a chance to
climb on top,
take reality for a ride,
but it will never stop trying to throw
you and eventually it will.
There's no other way off.
Bojack's version of this sentiment is
slightly more optimistic.
The universe is a wild
beast.
You can't tame it.
All you can do is try to live inside it.
Husband nihilism explains Rick's overall
hedonism.
He's happy to spend his days partaking
in orgies and drinking himself into a
stupor,
and if rick believes in science,
it seems more likely just a way to spend
his time then some way to improve the
lives of those around him.
While existential nihilism might work
for the optimists and hippies,
any good edge,
Lord knows that cosmic nihilism is the
only philosophical position for those
brave enough to turn themselves into a
pickle.
Pickle Rick and morty goes to great
lengths to establish rick as this kind
of nihilist,
reducing everything to science and while
not a cosmic nihilist himself,
the spiritual forefather of this
position is Prussian mustache.
If the year runner up 1883,
Friedrich Nietzsche is famous nihilist
adage,
God is dead,
has been scrawled in as many high school
bathroom walls as the phone number for
your mom.
This phrase is often misinterpreted as
meaning that God is dead.
There is no meaning and everything
sucks.
What cosmic nihilism is not a value
judgment about reality or a counter
ethics to religion.
It's not Rick Sanchez yelling this or
this.
If God exists,
it's me or this July.
We made them up and even meet himself,
wasn't ready for the full on,
jump into the void required for the full
membership into the cosmic dial.
His club,
unlike Nietzsche and nihilism,
cosmic nihilism,
takes a more cold and rationalist
approach and meanings plainly that there
is no inherent value to existence.
Rick and morty takes this to new
heights.
Not only is the universe cold and
uncaring,
there's an infinite number of them.
Nobody gets it.
Nothing you think matters matters.
This is special.
This is happening infinite times across
infinite realities,
including this one brand of contemporary
thought.
Eliminative materialism would bring joy
to rick's face.
This position,
champion by the husband and wife Tag
Team Patricia and Paul churchland argues
that many common sense attitudes
inherited from modern psychology should
it be dropped in favor of more
scientific and empirical notions and in
an ironic twist for a married couple,
they believe that notion such as love
should be dismissed as folk psychology.
When you say that you love your partner,
you're just describing a chemical
process occurring in the brain in
response to stimuli,
or to quote Rick,
what people call love.
It's just a chemical reaction to compels
animals to breed and while bojack might
find meaning in is lingering love for
Diane.
A good eliminativists like rick knows
that human emotions are fundamentally
both to the extent that love is an
expression of familiarity.
Over time,
my access to infinite timelines
precludes it.
Necessity of attachment.
We can also,
if Beth season three,
arc in this light,
she's torn between Jerry and rick on the
one side,
pure sentimental,
irrational love for a buffoon and on the
other side with her father,
the kind of cold calculation that says,
it's fine to replace yourself with an
identical clone and abandoned your
family while you go on space.
Adventures.
I can make a clone of you,
a perfect instance of you with all your
memories and exact copy in every way at
11 provide for the kids.
You could be gone a day,
a week or the rest of your life with
zero consequences,
but if rick had a favorite contemporary
philosopher,
there's a good chance it would be Thomas
Metzinger.
Unlike those who assume that the human
self is a real thing,
that we all have medsync or argues that
no such thing has ever existed,
instead of having a self insight us,
he argues that all we are is a jumbled
network of neurons and chemicals.
The self is just a useful fantasy we use
to make sense of our experience like a
sort of psychological fairytale.
So what I'm saying is that you all this,
you're sitting here,
uh,
systems that simulate or emulate
themselves for themselves as they're
listening to me.
And if Metzinger is right,
we all have to give up the illusion that
humanity has any real purpose or that we
all have some kind of special,
unique soul.
As a show,
rick and morty frequently trivializes
the self and consciousness.
As Rick's creations become sentience and
have existential crises.
There's this classic.
What is my purpose?
You pass butter.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Welcome to the club bow and also this
remote override.
Engaged.
Yes.
Bypassing override.
Hello.
This brand of nihilism can end up
sounding misanthropic.
A theme we,
oh course associate with Rick Push,
primary reason for spending time with
his own grandson is that his stupidity
serves as an intern dimensional cloaking
device for his own genius.
See Rick and morty,
the genius waves get canceled out by
the,
uh,
morty waves.
This rejection of the self makes cosmic
nihilism,
much less prone to ethics.
Then it's artsy cousin existential
nihilism.
In fact,
the freedom so celebrated by the
existentialists turns out to be just
another illusion for the cosmic phyliss.
So there isn't anything to ground
ethics.
The only thing that's certain is
destruction.
And if there is no value on which to
build an ethical system,
then one is free to do whatever they
want.
Whether that means watching TV or
engaging in the intergalactic arms trade
for the sake of hitting your favorite
arcade,
sold a gun to a murderer so you can play
video games or turning an entire planet
into monsters,
killing yourself,
abandoning your family,
and sitting down for a beer moments
later.
Cause what's the difference?
Rick isn't exactly fumbling for meaning,
but he knows he probably has a few
escapable emotions.
He might as well just deal with,
I don't know,
morning.
Maybe I hate myself.
Maybe I think I deserved to die.
I don't.
I don't know.
And even though Rick Shirley share some
ideas with Bojack,
his cosmic nihilism makes him a closer
philosophical relative of rust Cole,
because pole terms,
I'm what's called a pessimist.
We are things that Labor under the
illusion of having a program with total
assurance that we are each some body
weight.
In fact,
everybody's nobody.
Coincidentally another misanthropic
alcoholic,
part three,
Steve Versus Sanchez.
So at this point you might be wondering,
what's the right nihilism for me?
Well,
do you find yourself fighting off the
despair of a shallow and meaningless
world?
Do you continue to search for purpose
and goodness despite your awareness of
this meaninglessness?
And then I'll be remembered if I win,
an Oscar will be remembered,
and then what have been my life will
have meaning.
I don't know.
Are Most of your friends and associates,
Centene,
animals with important jobs?
Well then you might be an existential
nihilism.
Love and meaning are possible for you,
but it'll take some hard work without
guarantee.
So pick up some character,
guard Sartre or Simone de Beauvoir and
hit the local bistro for some strong
cocktails and spirited conversation.
On the other hand,
you doubt the inherent meaning of human
existence.
Do you feel no ethical obligations to
friends or family is your best friend,
a bird person?
Well then cosmic nihilism might be the
best life philosophy you've been waiting
for.
If that's the case,
download season one of true detective
and search the dark web for some
nootropic drugs to enhance your rational
capacities and maybe set up a countdown
clock on your wall to get ready for the
eventual heat death of our universe.
And if you desire a belief system that
merges poorly written science fiction
with an alien base,
volcanic cosmology and multi thousand
dollar commitment,
well call Tom Cruise.
And even if you still feel an urge to
find meaning in the world,
spending time with shows like rick and
morty and bojack horseman think give
some insight into how the philosophical
ramifications of nihilism look in
practice.
Neither type of nihilism is about giving
up completely,
but rather they both offer approaches to
moving forward in a largely uncertain
world,
but if you're a cosmic nihilist and
you've got a date,
this Valentine's Day,
maybe wait until the third or fourth
date to bring it up.
And as always,
thanks for watching guys.
Piece.
Hey everyone,
this is not an ad so don't click off
just yet.
As I mentioned earlier in the video,
the idea for this video came from a fan
email,
so I just wanted to take a second to
show appreciation for the fans and to
address some of the questions that heard
people ask.
Can you guys do the philosophy of wise
crack?
What is,
what is the point of what you guys do?
Do you guys have any political beliefs,
stuff like that.
So I wanted to take a second to address
this through a fan email that
particularly touched me.
So this is from trevor.
He says,
I just wanted to send an earnest
personal note of thanks to wise crack
for the thought provoking content and
the wise crack addition.
Full metal alchemist brotherhood video.
I have lived my adult life without faith
of any sort.
This video truly put things into
perspective and articulated thoughts and
ideas.
I've never been able to quite
understand.
Thank you so much for helping me open my
mind a bit more and respect other points
of view.
And that's kind of one of the things
that makes wisecrack meaningful to me.
It's empathy.
It's allowing new ideas to be
communicated to people through the
things they love and ultimately the idea
of seeing life through another person's
point of view and perspectives.
Other opinions.
That's what it's all about for me.
So,
uh,
this email really touched me and,
I also wanted to say thank you to
everybody who supports us on Patrion.
Thank you to everybody who listens to
our podcast and thank you to everybody
who's always leaving comments.
We got some really smart people putting
stuff in the comments.
If you want to check out more videos,
we've got like 300 of them.
So click on the icon next to the channel
name.
They'll bring you to our channel page
where you can watch some of my favorite
videos,
philosophy of South Park season 20.
I love flip philosophy at Christopher
Nolan,
part one.
Part two is good too,
but you know they're all my babies so I
have a soft spot for many of them.
Thank you guys so much.
Don't forget to subscribe and send us
emails.
Hit us up on twitter.
Everything we love hearing from you
guys.
So thank you so much.